it's 60 years since one of the biggest
scandals in medical history the drug
thalidomide was supposed to help
pregnant women suffering from nausea and
sleeplessness but just one tablet could
cause severe malformations in unborn
children by the time thalidomide was
taken off the market for many it was
already too late
Peter Brown has always valued his
independence he was born with a
disability when his mother was expecting
him she took a single dose of the
sedative thalidomide leading to numerous
malformations
as far naturally it was a huge shock I
was practically welcomed into the world
with the Midwife screaming oh my God
life hasn't always been easy for the 60
year old and his family
this is I'm
the question of Fate but I've seen it
more as a challenge how can I make the
best of it
thalidomide was one of the biggest
medical disasters of the 20th century
some ten thousand children were born
with severe deformities often a single
pill was enough to inflict permanent
damage as in Peter Brown's case
Crown graduated in social studies and
went on to become a psychotherapist
after that he met his wife sibilu
he now manages the Christian non-profit
organization medical emergency Albania
I want to share some of the wealth and
opportunities that I've enjoyed and
continue to enjoy in Germany with people
who aren't as fortunate to have been
born in a wealthy country
found one's inclusion for all members of
society and he wants Society to learn
from all its members either means is the
helpful
is
every person is valuable as an
individual and every person has talents
that must be discovered and encouraged
and if I can contribute in some small
way to helping individuals Foster their
individuality capability and talent then
I think that I will have made a valuable
contribution
foreign
[Music]
received compensation from thalidomite
manufacturer gruntai but like other
victims he's still waiting for a
meaningful apology